so um hello you're killing it
dancing with the stars how are you
feeling how would you describe this
out of body experience that's all i keep
saying it just feels like a dream
it is a dream come true and i'm just
honestly
i feel like the happiest i've ever been
when i'm out on that dance floor like
something just comes over my body and
i'm just like
i love it but you've been on an
emotional roller coaster i mean it has
been
like this already for you how are you
doing mentally and emotionally
today mentally i'm good because
i went into this just
being like i'm gonna be the most
positive person through everything even
when
negative thoughts or um anxiety or
injuries come up i'm just gonna like
take everything day by day and try and
be in the moment and know that
everything is part of the journey
so mentally i'm doing great physically
i'm falling apart um my ankle's so much
better it still hurts but i mean
it's so much better than it was i
couldn't even put weight on it
at one point and now it's like i'm back
in heels
um my shoulder i'm pretty sure i have my
shoulder
oh yeah my shoulders killing me i just
learned to not complain about my
injuries anymore because i'm like
i think everybody's hurting during this
i think you all are just like
putting them on for such a grind for
hours and hours every day
that i'm like i think that's just part
of it you just have to
roll with the punches and um know that a
couple ribs are gonna pop out every once
in a while
caitlyn okay um no but what was it with
your ankle what because at one point we
were like did you break something
like what i i honestly thought i had a
fracture at one point only because i
could not put weight on it but at the
same time i was like there's nothing
specific that happened
that i would have been like oh i can
pinpoint the moment and that's when i
heard it it was just like
over time i think i had a shoe size that
was too big for me
so dancing in like three inch heels with
a like wobbly ankle
was just like putting so much pressure
on that area
and then i have like a tiny bit of
scoliosis so i think it all
honestly started from my back into my
hip my knee started to hurt and then it
went all
the pressure in my ankle so it wasn't
once oh wow
yeah it was just more like i'm not i
mean it's been quarantined so when's the
last time i've even put on heels i don't
know
let alone dance for hours in them that's
right oh my gosh well we're so glad that
you're doing
doing better and your viennese walls
dedicated to your boyfriend jason was
so incredibly beautiful and emotional
what did he say
directly after i want to know oh i
facetimed him as soon as i
could and he was like kate i
cried and i was like oh that's so sweet
but
i just keep saying like it's the least i
could do for him he's just been such a
trooper through
moving across and being able to work
from home taking care of the dogs like
he's just like oh anything for this
dream of yours and so i just was like
doing a dedicated dance to him oh my
gosh speaking of dogs mine are barking
as you can probably hear
um i love that you have your dogs with
you and every night
they're spooning you oh my gosh i they
are
so therapeutic to us we just i mean you
know how
that love between uh you know your dogs
and you and
i know like some people are like don't
let them sleep in their bed and we tried
to do that i'm like no
i sleep better with them than i do
without so uh even though pinot sleeps
on our head it's just they're
they're the best dogs and we just love
them so much
oh my gosh they're so cute yeah we sleep
with our dogs too i mean
once it starts like you can't really
undo it it's just like a done deal
yeah for sure your dancing partner you
two gel
so well together um what do you think it
is that
created that magic like you guys are
great thank you for saying that
i honestly think we both just want this
so badly
and we are both so disciplined
and want to work hard and he's just he's
a very good teacher because he's
he's very patient um sometimes sometimes
i'll be like
oh my gosh don't get mad at me i can't
get this one step because
i think he thinks i should be able to
just pick these things up sometimes but
overall he's so patient and like a
really good teacher
and i just feel like we have a really
good
friendship in the studio too we're both
really honest with each other
and i don't know i just feel like we
both really want to be here
has he been showing you pictures of his
baby every day and i'm like
i just want to go early just so we can
like go through his baby album because
that's the cutest baby
i've ever seen and he just lights up
when he talks about him and he just it's
so cute and i'm i wish i could hold that
baby but it's 20 20.
oh my god exactly are you getting baby
fever i thought i read somewhere where
you were like
jason oh yeah it's
i mean i think i've had baby fever for
like five years now but uh
being around any babies or seeing baby
pictures i'm like oh gosh i can't wait
till that time comes
oh amazing i'm you know we were talking
about your your coach
your mom was a ballet dancer is that
right yeah so what does she
think of all of this like is she calling
you giving you pointers like what what's
happening with mama
oh yeah she's she's calling me every
time
i'll show her like our practice videos
and she'll be like you need to spot more
on these turns and you need to do this
and um so i feel like i've got two
coaches in my corner here but
she's just so proud i feel like dancing
with the stars is one of her favorite
shows of all time because
of her love for dance so to know that i
am on it and she gets to watch me on her
favorite show she's just
so ecstatic that's amazing how's the
support been from
your home country hot from canada how's
that been
it's so nice because it's so weird that
canadians can't vote
they can't right it blows up
it's so terrible and i think two years
no i don't know how many years ago but
one of the property brothers was on
and yeah and and they made it so that
canadians could vote
i'm like hello i need my canadians but
it's so nice because even though they
can't vote i still get
so much support from canada so it's been
amazing
and some pretty big support from some
celebrities like lady gaga can you just
what how's that feel i still
like sometimes i feel like it hasn't
even hit me yet because i'm like
i just my jaw drops every time i even
think about it i'm like the queen
herself lady gaga who is like the most
incredible
performer and so much talent and for her
to say she enjoyed watching
our performance i'm like i i just
i can't even wrap my head around it it's
pretty amazing
well you're it's because you're doing so
great i mean have you had any chance to
assess your competition i mean
everyone's doing
really really well who's impressing you
the most right now
i can't believe how good everyone is on
the season
like it's blowing my mind
and i really think that neve has
potential to take it very far um
neve and who else was i really impressed
with i mean honestly everybody i love
watching nelly
i just love his energy he's so good
yeah so totally yeah um now we obviously
have to talk to you about the upcoming
season of the bachelorette will you be
watching
with all the practices going on of
course well i'm like
can i request tuesday nights off and
like practice in the morning because i
need to watch this season
it looks like it's gonna be such a doozy
we all still like
i know we all have an idea in our head
of what's gonna happen but how it'll
play out who knows
i'm just like so excited to see what
happens
well that's it i mean we talk about you
know some great changes that are
happening on the show
the direction of the franchise going
with casting tasha and matt as
leeds yeah it's such an important
evolution talk a little bit about that
yeah i've always said like with a
bachelor i know they've stuck to this
format that they're used to
they've gotten the heat for a lot of
things in the past and
at the same time i've noticed that just
recently they've started evolving as a
show
and whether that's talking about
religion sex
i think they should talk politics like
important things that you would have
in a relationship that kind of
conversation so for them to be evolving
in the time that we're in right now is
so important and i'm just
so happy to see it yeah i understand you
have some really exciting news about a
birth
of a spade and sparrow in canada how
about
everything oh my gosh i the second i
started
this wine label i was like it was it was
a lot easier to get it in
in the states and with shipping and
everything and i was like no i need my
canadians to have this wine
um so we've worked really hard to get it
there just
i mean i didn't know how much work this
was going to be to have a wine label i
thought i'd be like oh i'll just you
know
try the wine yep i like it slap a label
on it no there's so much hard work that
goes into it and part of that is
shipping and getting it into the places
that i want it to be so
um done a lot of hard work and finally
it is in
some places in canada but we need to get
it everywhere there
that's amazing yes doing something like
that is such hard work
and congratulations to you that's
absolutely huge
so well i know you're in between all the
dancing right now
what dance are you working on right now
what can you tell us like every week
nyla says to me mommy what's the theme
the disney theme had her going but you
know what's the theme
well she might not know this era but
it's going to be 80s night
uh coming up on on monday and i am
obviously like scrunchies and all of
that 80s vibe and 80s fashion i'm just
here for it so
um we are doing a tango which i'm so
excited about
because pangos is one of the ones i've
been looking forward to
and the judges last week said you know
we've seen you do the
lyrical style the elegant ballroom
styles
um we want to see something different
now tango is still
ballroom style but it's very quick sharp
and to an 80s song
and we're doing like a serious 80s
breakdown
at one part of the dance so it's gonna
be really fun
you